عند ضريح الشيخ بشاره الخوري اولي رئيسا
للجمهوريه اللبنانيه وضع اكليل من الزهور
25 ضريحا للرجالات الاستقلال زاره وزراء
حكومه تصريف الاعمال تكريما لاعطاءات
دفعوا احيانا حياتهم ثمنا لها لكن احياء
هذا اليوم الذي يكتسب رمز المعنويه لدى
اللبنانيين سيتوقف هنا
لاحتفال عسكريا مركزيا بظل غياب رئيس
الجمهوريه
سيناريو يتكرر للمره الثالثه مع شعور منصب
الكرسي الاول
وما يطور الفراغ ما بيخلينا ان احنا ما
نحتفل بعيد الاستقلال نحن بالمناسبه
على الالتزام بالدستور الدستور الطائف الى
عروبه لبنان
بالحكم يعني احنا بنؤكد عليه يوم بنعيشوا
كل يوم وهذا السبيل للاستقرار السياسي ولا
خلاص لبنان ازميته كلها
الى وصول ميشيل سليمان الى سده الرئه
كان هذا اول فراغ بعد اتفاق الطائف يتبعه
فراغ تعدل عامين قبل ان يصبح حليفه حزب
الله ميشال عون الرئيس الثالث عشر
للجمهوريه هو رغم الانهيار الاقتصادي فشل
مجلس النواب تجنب الفراغ للمره الثالثه مع
استمرار حزب الله بوضع شروط ومواصفات
رئيسا يحفظ ظهر الحليف
واضح ولا من التيار ولا من القوات ولا
السلطه الدينيه اذا بدك ولا من الكتائب
ولا من الافرقه الاخرين فعمليا لحد هلا هو
ما عنده اي غطاء مسيحي اذا بده يجي بهذه
الظروف بده يفرده حزب الله بيكون عم عم
اذا بدنا زوجين عم يدعس هذه الاراده
المسيحيه هي سبب التعقيد الاساسي
الداخل اللبناني من ملء الفراغ بمرشح
توافقيه لا يبدو ان الخارج يضع لبنان على
السلم اولوياته لحل خلافه الداخل استمر
الشعور الاخير 30 شهرا قبل ان تتبنى القوى
السياسيه مرشح حزب الله لكن الظروف
السياسيه تبدو مختلفا اليوم ولن ترضخ
المعارضه لمرشح ينتمي لمحور الحزب غنوه
يتيم العربيات